joining me now wisconsin congressman
mike gallagher former marine counter
intel officer and a member of the armed
services committee welcome congressman
thank you for joining us tonight um i'm
going to get right to it do you agree
with that gold star mom that this could
have been avoided because joe biden
chose to have this you know artificial
deadline because of 9 11.
of course i think even for the
proponents of withdrawal and i myself
wanted us to keep a small
counter-terrorism force and keep bagram
as a way of projecting power took
against china over the long term but
even if you disagree with that there was
a way to do this that wasn't such a
humiliating
fiasco and obviously surrendering bagram
and pulling out military assets before
we had gotten every american citizen out
of the country will go down as one of
the worst foreign policy mistakes in the
history of united states foreign policy
and so this president to add insult to
injury has been lying to the american
people for two weeks he said al qaeda
has been decimated in afghanistan not
true he said our allies didn't have
concerns with the way in which this has
been conducted not true he said
americans weren't having trouble getting
to the airport well obviously we just
left hundreds if not thousands of them
behind so that was a massive lie the
foundation of our foreign policy has
always been peace through strength will
abide in doctrine is to sow chaos
through weakness and weakness invites
aggression and i fear we've only begun
to see the aggression from our
adversaries internationally because of
this absolute disaster well congressman
you mentioned bagram air base and that
was general milly who said we could take
that down and um you know
do the withdrawal without having
anything bad happen or at least not
having our soldiers killed that did not
happen our own jennifer griffin asked
general milley what will be facing in
terrorism now that we've withdrawn from
afghanistan and now that the taliban is
in total control here's what he said
i don't know if the taliban is going to
be able to consolidate power and
establish governance they may be maybe
not
but i think there's at least
a very good probability of a broader
civil war and that will then in turn
lead to conditions that could in fact
lead to a reconstitution of al qaeda or
a growth of isis or other myriad of
terrorist groups
so congressman if he thought that
terrorism was going to increase after we
got out of afghanistan and lost that
base why did he you know advise the
president that it was okay to move
forward with this decision in this
manner
well i hope that he mentioned that
during the debates over withdrawal
because if he didn't that is
unbelievable and here's the reality the
biden administration did force the
military to draw down to 600 troops and
then they had to secure the embassy and
kabul airfield but they didn't even
secure the embassy and that's the moment
at which you got to throw your rank on
the table and say if you go forward mr
president you know i believe this is a
lawful order but i am resigning and thus
far only a marine corps lieutenant
colonel has had the temerity to resign
in the face of a disagreement with the
commander-in-chief so there needs to be
a thorough investigation into the way in
which this absolute blunder
occurred and i fear and we need people
to be held accountable on our side
whether it's the military and the
highest levels of the state department
the national security council not only
for the disaster of the withdrawal but
also just for the deception with which
it was carried out and i do believe
rachel fundamentally this administration
believes that this is a a news cycle
they can manage and get away with this
that as long as they have friendly
allies in the media they can get away
with this but this is a matter of life
and death it's not a matter of tweets i
agree what can congress do because i
really do believe that the american
people think they are getting away with
it they're not even apologizing
a few things one i had a bill on the
floor last week that would have
prevented us from recognizing the
taliban as a legitimate government and
critically prevented
any uh money from being sent to the
taliban so that we don't end up bribing
the taliban in order to get the american
citizens that we left their back that
should be a minimum foundation going
forward we also need a full accounting
of all the weapons we abandon that are
now in the hands of the taliban and we
also need to plan from this
administration for rescuing our people
and we do not have one right now
thank you congressman gallagher
we'll be coming back to you later with
some more information
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else